I see you were confused by my apparently
confusing statement but let me make it
abundantly clear a man cannot be a woman
I mean it's obviously being pushed by
politicians primarily that's why at the
United Nations it's not politics
politicians are going to push political
issues right it's politics not science
that's my point yes because if you think
that speech is violence
[Music]
shoulders of John
and you think that you're flying but
you're not we are dwarfs standing on the
shoulders of that great man and we spit
down on him in our ingratitude how
pathetic they called me a fascist for
defending George Washington
behold your country leftists before we
go I should point out there are people
in the back of the room who have put
tape over their mouths as though they've
been censored as though they're not able
to speak so I just like to take the
opportunity nobody is stopping you from
speaking nobody is We're actually
inviting you to speak if anybody would
like to come up and ask a question now's
your opportunity you can cut the entire
line would anybody who has a masking
tape over their mouths well you don't
have masking tape oh you can come and
ask a question too but I I mean
specifically the people who are making a
statement and saying I am being censored
would any of you like to remove the
masking tape which you put on yourself
and come up here and ask a question or
would you rather stand back there and
play the victim
I think we got my answer okay next
guideline all of that has been missed by
the ignorant activists who insist the GW
ditch the colonial the point that
they're missing is this the Colonials
that the mascot represents were not
Defenders of colonialism in fact they
were the opposite of Defenders of
colonialism they fought a bloody war
they risked their lives to end
colonialism in America and to end rule
in Great Britain they wanted their
political Independence
oh there these kids are really proving
me wrong
you see because my premise was that
these students are ignorant and uh not
well behaved but they're proving me
wrong tonight
[Applause]
they they called me a fascist for
defending George Washington
behold your country leftists
behold I hope the cameras catch all the
faces here too
because I think this school costs about
seventy thousand dollars a year to
attend this is the job they've done
[Applause]
hey hey just just for the people in the
room if you have like that guy right
there what did I say what did I say that
you disagree with does any anything what
did what did I say that any of you
disagree with can you name one thing yes
what what is it what is it
what did I say I can't hear over all the
shouting and the screeching and the
what what did I say that you disagree
with
could you
Thunder I can't I can't what are you
saying
I can't hear it so they can't name one
thing they can't name one thing
um I wanted to mention a few points that
you brought up earlier in your speech
you said that because we think walls are
wrong we must also think walls are
sinful no that's what Nancy Pelosi said
that's not what I said that's what okay
so Nancy that's immoral walls are
immoral and sinful okay
um so you also said that the U.S
intervened he that the U.S funnels money
into other countries right in Aid and
things like that right much more than
any other country in the history of the
world by a long shot
um did you also talk about how the U.S
intervenes in countries in other ways
like War
um and that the US is commit is tearing
up these countries which countries in
particularly
um okay so you mean when the United
States included Afghanistan to overturn
the Taliban do you think yeah well
you're you're because you're making
statements that are not specific so I
want to get to the heart of your
question okay but let me just with what
I'm giving you right now try to answer
my question
okay so if the U.S is intervening and
intervening in countries and when we
give foreign aid we have immigrants that
are fleeing where do these where do you
expect these immigrants to go when the
U.S intervenes in these countries that
don't ask for U.S Intervention which
country well uh yes if the Taliban in
Afghanistan didn't ask
well I guess they did ask for it
specifically narrow it down to any sort
of I know you can't narrow it down
because when you get specific your point
falls apart in the general in the
general your point sounds like it makes
sense but in the specific it doesn't
make sense are you gonna let me okay
so
where do you expect these immigrants to
go
you're blaming the United States for the
free actions of people what's this I
mean if if your point is you know what's
out of these people's control is U.S
intervention in their countries right
well U.S foreign aid is intervention in
other countries I don't think that they
would say no to that sort of
intervention what specific intervention
do you take issue with what specific
intervention do you believe is is
egregious and the fault of the United
States and demands that we not have
National borders
um what if somebody I support over there
is holding up a sign that says
anti-immigrant rhetoric is violent free
speech and the reason they're holding up
that sign is because
this anti-immigrant rhetoric became
violent when children began being put in
cages and I mean during the Obama
Administration
oh okay all right well go protest Barack
Obama don't go protest me to continue
right you're set you're you're saying
that the the anti-immigrant rhetoric
became violent when Barack Obama put
kids in cages and this is somehow my
responsibility what makes it violent is
that there's children in cages you
mentioned that women
you mentioned women that are raped when
they cross the border but you're not
mentioning the children that are being
raped in the detention centers at your
borders well 80 percent of women and
girls who cross the border illegally are
raped along that journey by the sadistic
sociopaths who have been permitted to
run free along the border what
percentage of children who have been
brought in by their parents to this
foreign country what percentage of
children are you suggesting are being
raped by U.S government officials
where are the children in the detention
centers
as well you made a claim and I'm just
asking what percentage of the children
being you you said U.S children and U.S
detention are being raped by government
officials do you have any evidence for
that whatsoever officials you said
they're being raped in detention centers
by whom are you suggesting okay but
who's keeping these detention centers so
you don't have an by whom are you saying
they're being victimized if there's a if
there is an epidemic of children being
victimized in these detention centers
and you have some evidence of that you
better present that that sounds like a
terrible thing
in these detention centers so children
are separated from their parents not
because of a policy of Donald Trump not
even because of a policy of Barack Obama
but because of a policy that was
determined in 1997 called the Flores
agreement during the Clinton
Administration and the reason for that
is that when illegal aliens come into
our country they are apprehended by law
enforcement but if they're held for
longer than a short period of time you
can't put children in jails I don't
think anybody wants us to put children
in jails that is literally caging
children so the children are separated
from their parents because the parents
are dealt with by law enforcement and
the children are dealt with by the
Department of Health and Human Services
the the only alternative to this would
be to put children in jails or else to
let the parents go free without any
consequences for entering the country
which is to say the only alternative is
totally open borders in the United
States is that what you're suggesting
you're saying the children in cages
right now aren't which children are like
how many children are in cages right now
the children at the at the time
you're so certain of this how many
children I received more than 4 500
complaints in four years about the
sexual abuse of immigrant children who
were held at government-funded detention
facilities including an increase in
complaints while the Trump
administration's policy of separating
migrant families at the border well
there's been there's also been a surge
in illegal immigration we now have 3 000
people per month coming into this
country and a surge in children so
naturally any offense that involves
children is going to increase I agree
with you illegal immigration is a
horrific and immoral action and it
should not be encouraged by Craven
politicians who think that they can grab
a few extra votes by encouraging the
victimization of desperate foreigners
and their children is there is there an
example you said I told a lot of lies
tonight what would be an example of
advice to not well no you didn't say
last night you lack rationality you
didn't cite any evidence to to talk
about the climate change I said that the
the mankind is not going to be wiped out
within 20 years because no scientists
I'm sorry science would disagree uh
which scientist the uh the 97 percent of
all scientists who say that one to two
degrees Celsius
will Mount the ice caps such that there
will be rising sea levels mass
extinctions and it won't end the Earth
but it will change to a certain point
the Ecology of our planet such that it
is much more difficult for humans to
survive that is the consensus and a lot
of climate change deniers like yourself
like Ben like Clavin they they
perpetuate that this is all a liberal
hoax and that in that science I'm not
saying it's a liberal I mean it's
obviously being pushed by politicians
primarily that's why at the United
Nations it's not politics politicians
are going to push political issues right
it's politics not science that's my
point
something
no you take the science and then you say
I don't which study because what you're
what's your citing that 97 number has
been around for a long time Al Gore used
it in his movie one issue with that is
first of all science is not made by
consensus but second of all the
questions that were asked were such
broad questions as to a whole array of
scientists many of whom had no expertise
in the climate whatsoever so the the to
use a a consensus number especially one
that's so old and was has been so
manipulated by politicians is I think
not really getting to the point we don't
we don't take polls to figure out
scientific data so if you think the
world is going to end in 20 years as
Paul Oh I thought you said that you
thought so that's going to change to a
certain point such a human habitation
will be more difficult and it will be
vastly different I'm not a doomsday you
know idiot and it's not an old figure
it's ongoing it's right now no no it's a
that's a figure is decades old right now
the 97 figure is decades old you say to
the list of statistics physics in your
talk which you claim support the idea
that legal immigrants are dangerous or
criminals I'm I'm I cited a number of
Statistics that show that they commit
federal crimes at a significantly higher
rate than native born Americans yeah
okay
so what role do you think that
structural racism and inherent bias has
to play in those statistics I don't
think that the people who enter this
country illegally are forced to do so by
some sort of systemic racism there's no
systemic American racist going down to
El Salvador and saying you better get up
and sneak into the United States and
there's nobody in the United States who
forces people who come here illegally to
commit crimes I think the premise of
this question is actually quite
offensive though it's a popular
assumption which is that illegal aliens
somehow don't have free will it's the
assumption that illegal aliens are
somehow morally
uneducated they have no sense of right
and wrong they have no ability to
control their their emotions and their
impulses this is obviously profoundly
racist and not true we have free will we
have the ability to do what we want to
do this is why by the way the majority
of Hispanic Hispanic people in the
United States and Hispanic voters oppose
illegal immigration the the races are
exactly the same the ethnicity is
exactly the same the question of crime
is different because race does not
determine your criminality
that's no I'm saying I'm saying that
people of color are more likely to be
convicted of crimes unfairly than white
people they're more likely to commit
certain crimes that's true I don't think
that's because of their race I think
it's because of aspects of their Free
Will and perhaps of culture that's not
true I'm talking about that is true I
mean what I just said is true I'm not
quite sure you're getting your
statistics from and you choose from the
federal government you choose to
interpret them in your Bureau of Justice
statistics Department Homeland Security
well you you said you didn't know where
I got my statistics from and I'm telling
you where I get them from well it would
have been nice if you could have let me
finish my sentence anyway I was
answering your question
you are using your statistics for your
agenda and that's you're I'm citing
statistics because they're true
I'm talking about the fact that I am I'm
a faculty here I also support I support
uh um protester in the back what do you
support specifically do you do you think
that anti-immigrant rhetoric is violent
free speech Yes because you think that
speech is violence uh no I think that's
what that sign says a conversation that
you're having is oppressive
um and so I am oppressing people by what
I'm doing so I am I am exerting violence
on people by my speech that's what the
sign says and that's what you just said
it contributes and the protester is
saying that's exactly what I'm doing and
she's saying that's exactly what her
sign means so that means that you a
faculty member at an American Public
University paid for by taxpayer dollars
are conflating speech with violence
yes
um speech can be violent what you are
saying contributes to systemic racism in
this country it means that my students
of color are pulled over and accused of
stealing a car when they did not I'm not
pulling anybody over for stealing
anymore I see many people of many
different races in this room I I they
all seem to be doing just fine I don't
think I any any of them have felt
violence because they listened to a
lecture on on basic facts about our
immigration system
the question was have I asked people in
this room if they've felt as though some
violence has been committed on them no I
haven't asked because no violence has
been committed on you because violence
is not a subjective feeling violence is
an objective fact I can objectively
gauge whether or not someone has become
violent the other day I was at the
University of Missouri Kansas City some
protester attacked me with some weird
chemical that was an objective act of
violence but somebody disagreeing with
me such as some people in this room are
doing are not committing violence on me
and I would say to you as a faculty
member at a taxpayer-funded university
this is the foundation of liberal
education if you cannot understand that
there is a difference between speech and
violence you don't understand anything
that undergirds the liberal arts or
liberal education and that is a real
shame and I say this with all respect
and with great distress for our
universities if our teachers don't under
understand the difference between
between ideas and violence between
speech and violence then they are in no
position to educate the next generation
of Americans I wish I didn't have a time
constraint because I have a lot of
things I want to get through but I'm
going to read two quotes and ask how you
justify this as quote a hero and quote
one of the greatest men in history as
you said through yourself where are your
quotes from the quotes are from his uh
Journal so where's his journal I'm sorry
from the Journal of Christopher Columbus
okay in his journal he says quote let us
in the name of the Holy Trinity go on
sending all the slaves that can be sold
he also says quote the Indians are so
naive I will bring as much gold and
slaves as you need that actually was not
in his journal that was to the court in
Madrid I assume it wasn't in his journal
because he would be writing to himself
right so you're saying Christopher
Columbus
agreed in a letter to his bosses who
were funding his voyage that he would
fulfill the terms of his voyage that's
what you're saying this is some show
there's there's two parts to it the
first one was from his journal where he
quite literally said let us in the name
of the Holy Trinity go on sending all
the slaves the second one was to the
court in Madrid appeasing them saying
yes let's go get all these slaves well
you mentioned in the name of the Holy
Trinity uh Christopher Columbus baptized
many natives he did it personally and he
obviously was bringing the faith to the
new world you're at a Catholic
University if you believe that the faith
is true and good and beautiful as I do
as all Christians ought to do then
that's a wonderful thing to spread the
gospel to people who've never heard it
you've misheard the quote the last part
I don't think I misheard the quote but
you can repeat it if you like in the
name of the Holy Trinity what should we
do in that name go on sending all the
slaves that can be sold all so he sent
slaves to the new world that is true
that or is back to Spain that is true
that was part of the deal and if you
listen to my lecture I'm not sure I
heard your question but I'm not sure you
heard my lecture he agreed to the uh
encomienda system as a political
concession because he was out foxed by a
local mayor named Roldan this was the
cause of much of his consternation in
the new world it's the reason that
bobadilla was able to take over and
usurp control from him in the West
Indies this is a political reality this
is not a beautiful thing it's a terrible
thing slavery is an awful thing none of
us disagrees with that but for us now
as people who have benefited all people
of the whole world who have benefited
from the greatest country the most
profitable the most charitable the most
Equitable the most just the one that
allows you to stand there and ask me
that question for us to spit on that man
who made all of it possible because he
made some moral concessions in order to
take the most ambitious Voyage at that
time in the history of man is so
bizarrely ungrateful it is so ignorant
of historical and political realities as
to be naive and sophomoric
um well I my question was how can you
justify calling him a hero I just
Justified it that's my explanation I
think that you're standing on the
shoulders of giants and you think that
you're flying but you're not we are
dwarfs standing on the shoulders of that
great man and we spit down on him in our
ingratitude how pathetic I'm a full-time
Professor here I also am
Italian-American and I happen to agree
with the protester in the back
well I have to say as a professor that
you would come I really appreciate that
because I know students come out a lot
but professors don't always come out to
hear opposing points of view so that's a
wonderful thing
it's my duty
um
but I've left you speechless you have
dazzled you thank you
in
you know in 1492 before
a racist and genocider came to this land
there were people living here
every inch of this land was occupied
it just as a matter of History not every
inch of the land was occupied it was it
was there were huge areas that were
completely Wilderness I'd like to I was
quiet the entire time you spoke
there those people still exist
the North American indigenous people
Central and South American they're still
here
and
I would like to know how you can say
that they have no ancestral claim to
this land and that as a white person you
can say that they cannot migrate freely
and cannot use the land freely that they
rightfully own and have for thousands of
years well Michael I'd like you to be
more specific which people specifically
and which land specifically because
there were lots of different peoples in
the northern and southern in North
America and South America at the arrival
of Christopher Columbus so which people
do you think have a claim to which land
I'm talking about the Native Americans
but there were many different Native
Americans need to name all the tribes
yeah sure and I'd like you to name it
and the reason I would like you to name
all the tribes is because there were
many tribes who conquered many other
tribes so just as an example that's
thank you just as an example the
Comanche Indians come in and they
conquer areas run by the Apache Indians
now the United States comes in and it
owns that land to which tribe should
that revert to which tribe should that
land revert the Comanche who had it
before us or the Apache who had it
before them moreover for the people who
still exist you're referring to
Christopher Columbus in an a-historical
Way by calling him some sort of racist
or some sort of genocidal Maniac the man
never committed any sorts of genocide at
all and he was actually known among the
Spanish explorers for his good treatment
of the natives that point is neither
here nor there and I encourage people to
read biographies of Christopher Columbus
because there's a lot of historical
fiction out there the point on that is
that when the Spanish came to this
country they did into this continent
they did create a new race known as
Latinos this is a mixture of Spaniards
and Native American populations so if we
are going to revert certain land to
Native populations why would we not then
immediately take that land away from
them because they also descend from
Spanish explorers in what sort of
atomized way would you define your own
race your own identity I think this is a
very backwards and ultimately impossible
view of personal identity that that puts
your your stock in some particular
ancestor rather than something that is
larger than yourself I think it's a
Madness of the modern left and it leads
to to Crazy policy proposals such as
saying that somebody who descends from a
native population in Colombia has a
right to move to any apartment he wants
to in New York because of race or
something
uh you I we certainly have a response
thank you for not answering my question
and in the future I think I did answer
you how specifically could I answer your
question if you could not lower the
microphone until the person's done
speaking I think that'd be better for
everyone thank you that's all
so you were done speaking
I think I think the the gentleman did
just fine then I like your cape thank
you it's a flag what's the flag Soviet
flag oh my gosh that's not good that's I
take it back and it is uh so you claimed
that the reason that there are more
transgender people now is because they
are more confused uh even today the hate
crimes against transgender people are
much higher than those against any other
demographic so is it not more likely
that there are more transgender people
now because are there more hate crimes
in the United States against transgender
people or Jews
I guess transgender but I am not sure
you you are certainly not sure that's
right it's uh the answer is Jews okay Dr
spin numbers thing though like you're
like it is a numbers thing but you cited
a numbers thing so then I'm citing a
different numbers point one percent of
people in America are transgender yeah
like 100 of them could be like affected
by crimes only one percent well we're
getting very confused with our numbers
if you're saying it's point one percent
of Americans are transgender we've also
heard it's 0.2 to point four percent and
now we're hearing the 12 of American
Millennials identify as transgender or
gender non-conforming so what number is
it I'm certainly confused and it seems
to me that these people are very
confused as well is it not though more
likely that people are identifying as
transgender now because of a decrease in
the percentage of hate crimes as opposed
to previous decades I I well the
identification is part of the confusion
because a man isn't a woman and a woman
isn't a man that's the confusion I see
you were confused by my apparently
confusing statement but let me make it
abundantly clear a man cannot be a woman
and a woman cannot be a man there is
sexual difference the Sexes are not
indistinguishable they're not
indiscernible and there's a great
confusion in our culture that men can be
women but they can't I'd like to start
off by noticing that as each Speaker
gets up here the speaker this speaker
then goes ahead and answers and his
supporters get to go ahead and applaud I
would like to start off by applauding
the people that have the courage to
stand up against this hate
you're certainly welcome to applaud
anybody you like I take no
responsibility for who applauds for what
well you haven't given them space that
that was my point
um but I do have I do have questions
here what I was saying is the structure
here has been very specifically designed
to go ahead and to support a particular
point of view I uh could you give an
example of that because here's what I
think happens people come up and ask me
a question and then I give them an
answer and then somebody else comes up
and asks me a question and then I give
them a different answer is could you
please show me the nefarious and unfair
structure of that I'll be happy to
because after their last comment you get
a chance to comment and your supporters
go ahead and applaud when when the
speaker is then going ahead and when the
when the person from the audience is
talking you immediately talk afterwards
and there's no yes that's true because
they're asking me a question because I'm
the speaker and they're the ones asking
the question exactly right so I guess
they can go give a speech somewhere else
and then their their supporters can go
and applaud them but that's not what
we're engaged in here so so you do agree
then that there was I agree that I'm
giving a speech and people are asking me
questions I agree with that yes I didn't
I didn't know that I had to clarify that
um so so let me go ahead and uh frankly
there's so much misinformation here I
don't even know where to start but I
will try you talk about melting pots and
assimilation
I don't know to what extent you cook in
the kitchen and you don't cook I have no
idea well I'm of Italian descent so I
can work my way around the kitchen a
little bit
that if that's the case then you will
know that a Melting Pot is not something
that you take apart you put the first
ingredient in and you add other things
and you expect everything else to go
ahead and take on the flavor of that
first ingredient rather a Melting Pot is
a is a mixture of different ingredients
and some of those ingredients you want
to blend in and other ingredients you
want them to maintain their character
and you don't want them to blend in very
much and you put them in a particular
order
and you you talk about what makes
America
there's plenty of things in this country
that are there are a huge problem and
there's plenty of things in this country
that are very good
one of the best things about this
country is
is that as each culture comes in we're
able to go ahead and look at that
culture and take on the best things from
that culture this America is not a
English only culture we have taken on
from all all different cultures and it's
it's the strength of this country that
we have gone ahead and taken on it's the
strength of this country that you can't
look at people and tell which ones are
Americans and which ones are not that's
what I said in my speech
um
that's literally what I said in my
speech what what you said is you expect
them to assimilate right I expect
assimilation and I said it's a beautiful
thing in this country that you can't
look at someone and tell who's the
American and who isn't but I said the
exact same line but you seem to imply
that when people come in well you know
what they say happens when you assume
yeah is there a question or is this a
speech Yes what's the question okay so
the question is do you realize
that a hundred years ago you you
mentioned that previously people have
come in and then they immediately
assimilate a hundred years ago there
were areas in New York City where you
couldn't function if you couldn't speak
Yiddish if you couldn't speak German if
you couldn't speak a Slavic language
130 years ago in Kansas the uh in a very
large area in Kansas German was such a
predominant language that the Native
Americans assumed that the language in
this country was German not English
we've never had a true tragedy we've
we've never had a situation where people
come in and it immediately start but I
never claimed that people immediately
assimilate I never claimed that in my
speech I think you're making fine points
they're just not points that in any way
contradict what I've been saying this
afternoon I'd like to ask just one more
question then I'll I'll leave
um in the past when uh the Young
Americans have had speakers here you
mentioned that each person gets one
question and you've been very
accommodating about letting many of us
have a conversation but in in the past
there's never been that kind of of a
statement and I'm just wondering why
there would be a statement here it
sounds like you're afraid of having a
conversation though I will admit that
you have been carrying on on a
conversation and
um I just I just want in closing I just
want to say that what's really important
is that we Embrace other ideas and other
cultures not that we assume or force
people to go ahead and take on what's
already there well I appreciate your
comments I would like to point out that
it seems you have criticized me for
saying things I didn't say I agree with
many of the points that you've made and
then you're criticizing other speakers
who have spoken for Young Americans
Foundation instead of me so I'm pleased
that you had a nice time at the lecture
I agree with many of your points and I I
love the open exchange of ideas a far
greater concern to society is the recent
scourge of cancel culture which
threatens to make our public discourse
coarser falser and crueler cancel
culture takes two forms
in one version cancel culture occurs
when a once obscure individual achieves
some modicum of fame or success at which
point a social media swarm stirs up and
digs up some tweet that that guy sent 10
years ago at which point his achievement
is totally taken away from him and he is
canceled
even the kindest of souls find
themselves subject to this sort of
cancel culture I'm not talking about
myself I'm talking
about a guy named Carson King just
recently an Iowa football fan Carson
King held up a sign in a game that said
please send beer money and it included
his venmo address
now his we have some people leaving
they're canceling Carson King too
well I'll tell you about Carson king and
you can leave him if you want he held up
that sign
and raised one million dollars and the
reaction that he got from the American
public was exactly the reaction that
we're seeing in this room people who
don't want to listen to a thing who
don't want to look at Grace who don't
want to live in a culture that takes
each other seriously but a culture that
merely wants to rip people down for no
reason now the one positive thing about
that culture is the minute that all the
Schmucks leave
it's a positive thing
the positive thing is the minute all the
Schmucks leave the people who are
waiting in line all the way out the door
they get to come in and fill the seat so
welcome to those of you who are not here
before
laughs
[Applause]